le plantain est une herbe sauvage
originaire d'europe et qui se retrouve
aujourd'hui aux quatre coins du monde
à la réunion il existe le gros plantain
reconnaissable par ses larges feuilles
et le petit plantain au feuillage plus
allongée le plantain banque d'atlanta la
rényon a deux qualités planta le gros
plantage un trou plutôt dans les bas
aussi comme elano léopard ce canal
menace mais ou bien moins d'oiseaux la
progrès nous reconnaît ali parce que le
feuilles les plus larges par rapport aux
petits plants ac me trouve dans les eaux
d'un quart aux géraniums aux temps de
karo kann donc s'attela le groupe lantin
ça plantait majors c'est bien peut-être
d'europe
bah il a fredo mouna mensah début quand
arrive la réunion et la propager il pour
parler précisément parce que tu regardes
bien la descente des petits ballets de
graines comme ça elle a demandé me les
petites graines consommateurs surtout
c'est parce qu'il est tombé un coin 6 ou
7 n'a de l'eau la moins poussées mais là
on vient dans trois mois le plan annan
en carreaux donc dans les pôles amis
s'implanter comme ça et vite fait vite
fait vainqueur au plantain pour que ça
de mon utilisation
que ce soit le petit pantin dans ta
zoreil lapin on appelle ça
quant à l'oreille la fin parce qu'il
ressemble à doha il a pas vraiment ou
bien le gros plant attentes quant à goma
0 planta major les files et l'âge de mon
nikon et ce à la réunion dans
l'utilisation pour problème les yeux
quand un accord contactez vite ou bien
on a mal aux yeux donc le plantain les
faciles à utiliser
facile à trouver un peu partout où ces
cas pas trop encore extermine ali à
cause de la foule désherbant donc de
planta il peut être bon par exemple la
houle un problème les yeux mélodieux ou
père sadique rosalie mettre dessus comme
ça c'est ma façon de faire 1 1 le gip
total à shiogama tijd en jeu impeccables
pour certains problèmes de dieu
la bleue avec caen lisieux le problème
il peut aussi boire plantain en même
temps couleurs les yeux pour l'action un
peu plus rapide le plan talent est
connue aussi pour les problèmes de peau
pour les cicatrisations dont coule à pic
à aucun répit car aucun insecte par
exemple propre lantin où le crash des
cieux et l'efficace où la fée ou à
blesser ou proposant au mix ali ou fait
un petit pas de plantes on m'a déçu l'y
aident à pau cicatriser le plantain les
connu aussi pour l'eczéma les bons pour
tous qui maladies de peau donc cette
petite plante que les traîtres très cher
moi particulièrement parce qu'il n'ya
bourgueil amène quelque chose comme à
endurer pendant 15 ans une certaine
allergie donc le plantain y aident aussi
en cas d'allergie le plan tel est bon
aussi pour les diarrhées les racines des
feuilles tous les bons pour le dire et
le plantain les ponts aussi il ya fait
arrêter des diarrhées et en même temps
les graines plants sains les graines
plantes à caen demande est constipé
alors qu'on ne moule est constitué vous
mettez y tremper les grandes ligues ont
fait ou aval ali et les bons mais là
dedans après il faut voir la dose ça pas
voir la tonne de graines plantées mais
un petit peu une grande plante 1
cuillère à café de graines de plantes
est dans un verre d'eau laisser un peu
les dents et les groupes nokia ou prouve
bien aller là où il faut donc tout est
bon dans le pater
dans le choix soit nous mettre carrément
teese comme ça d'un grand bouteille et
puis nos maîtres comme seule tige de
plantes lacets bois d'art dette que nous
mettre dans macération d'un bouteille ou
bien coupé coupé en petits morceaux
compagnie bonbons les connu pour ses
effets macération dans l'alcool pour les
douleurs pas confondre avec le branle
qu'on ne trouve plus souvent dans les
eaux de l'est odile différence est nette
d'un branle blanc et le branle bas les
voilà donc pareil nous couper en petits
morceaux
tout ça dans un bouteille avec d'alcool
dedans nous choisit nous quittant
l'école du match dans quand ils voient
en a assez des plantes dedans ilves
l'alcool dans s'était à nouveau mettre
un peu d'alcool dedans bien au cou il ya
toutes les plantes
un peu émoussé les saligues côté dance
d'un quoi ou ce qui fait chaud soleil
puis nous retourne ali tous les jours un
petit peu pendant quinze jours et donc
un jour où les bons pour frotter ou
douleur